all right these winds are bruising us a
little bit this morning boy they are
rough out there they've
been gusting over 30 miles an hour we
see the sun's on its way up but look at
the palm tree
it's having a hard time standing up
against these northerly winds
temperatures pretty much in the mid to
low 50s around the valley you can see
these sustained winds
over 15 miles an hour even nellis
sustained winds at 23 miles an hour that
is a lot of north wind
that cold front passed through just
around midnight last night
it is through the valley now and it has
opened the door for a cool down and
we'll feel it today
nellis near 50 mile an hour winds same
for laughlin
boulder city and mccarran both have had
30 plus mile an hour wind gusts
and i think we'll keep the winds pretty
much like that through the morning hours
and then the afternoon things will start
to relax a little bit except for out at
the lake and along the river
where wind advisories have been in
effect since early this morning
they'll go until 10 o'clock tonight 40
plus mile an hour wind gusts
easily again it's all a cold front and
along it very limited moisture but there
is some snow
up around denver even into the upper
midwest high pressure will rebuild
pretty quickly 69 today that's about 15
degree drop from yesterday's mid
80s those northwest winds will stay with
us again first half of the day really
strong
latter half of the day we'll relax a
little bit sunshine tomorrow for our
last day of march and mid
70s 80s jump in real quickly for the
start of april
and we're going to get our first 90
degree day there's about a 50 50 chance
that we'll even tie the record of 91 on
saturday before easter sunday
temps back off a little bit into the mid
80s 70s return
next week too soon it's too soon nate